what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it feels like it's been a little bit
since any Marvel Studios project has
dived into the Multiverse but that is
about to change with Loki season 2
coming next week just about a week away
from this Thursday and this is going to
really start the path to Avengers Secret
Wars everything's going to really start
to go down with Loki season 2 then we're
going into Deadpool 3. Dr Strange three
of course is going to be a big
Multiverse movie and we're hearing other
movies as well are going to start to
feature incursions such as the Marvels
or Captain Marvel 2. so really Loki
season 2 is marking a big change for the
MCU the path that leads to Secret Wars
in which we found out a little bit more
details about today and some of Secret
Wars might not actually be what we
thought it was going to be or I should
say how we thought it was going to be
but it is good nonetheless and a lot of
fans have been kind of scared and kind
of holding back with their expectations
for Secret Wars understandably so we got
our hopes up for Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness thinking that it
was just going to be Cameo after Cameo
after Cameo however a new report
suggests that it's okay to get our hopes
up for Avengers Secret Wars because it
is indeed going to be exactly what we
want it to be it's going to be what we
wanted Multiverse of Madness to be and
essentially we can expect a lot of
cameos from the X-Men to Venom to the
Fantastic Four we'll talk about all of
it in this video and break down a couple
of new reports today that we got for
Deadpool 3 and Avengers Secret Wars and
how exactly they are going to directly
tie into each other and Deadpool 3 is
going to tie into Secret Wars not Kang
Dynasty in fact it sounds like King
Dynasty isn't essentially a part one to
a part two which would be secret Wars
because it sounds like many movies are
going to go directly into Avengers
Secret Wars of course Kang Dynasty being
one of them but it sounds like Doctor
Strange 3 Deadpool 3 and of course
Avengers King Dynasty are all crucial
for what goes down in Avengers Secret
Wars and probably some other movies like
The Fantastic Four as well especially if
the rumors are true about it and it does
take place in Another Universe the MCU
is about to get crazy and we are super
excited so let's dive into what we know
first about Deadpool 3 because this will
go directly into Secret Wars and many of
you might have heard the report from a
couple of weeks ago that states that the
TVA is essentially going to be grabbing
characters from other universes and
bringing them into one Universe it's
essentially going to be secret Wars
battle World from the comics now we know
that the Multiverse is essentially going
to start collapsing incursions are going
to start to happen and we are basically
going to start to lose universes just
like they mentioned in doctor strange
and the Multiverse of Madness universes
are indeed going to be destroyed when an
incursion happens one of two things
could essentially happen one of the
universe gets destroyed or both of them
get destroyed in the case of doctor
strange and the Multiverse Madness
towards the end of the film we saw two
universes combined into one but both
were destroyed and the only remaining
Survivor was Doctor Strange a very evil
variant of doctor strange but nobody
else survived so that's what's happening
right now in the Marvel Cinematic
Multiverse and we're gonna see that in
Deadpool 3 as Deadpool kind of travels
throughout the Multiverse we're going to
see a lot of incursions start to happen
and the TVA is going to be very
selective in all of these universes that
are collapsing and they're essentially
going to pick people who they think will
essentially be valuable yesterday Grace
Randolph said this about Deadpool 3. she
was in her live stream yesterday she was
talking about Deadpool 3's box office
prospects during her live stream and she
said that based on what she's heard it's
gonna be a fantastic film and is
definitely going to gross a billion
dollars and she said she teases the
movie in two words Noah's Arc so what
that essentially tells us is that the
TVA is indeed trying to save people in
the story of Noah's Ark the world was
essentially going to be flooded
everything was going to be destroyed it
was up to Noah to get two of every kind
of animal a male and a female to
preserve them so they could mate with
each other so after the flood was done
they could be put back on Earth on the
solid ground that is and then start to
repopulate so that's kind of very
similar as to what's going to happen in
Deadpool 3. the TVA is going to save
Heroes that they think are going to be
able to help restore the Multiverse
eventually and who do you save from
universes if you're the TVA who could
potentially help restore the Multiverse
in the future well you save the
superheroes and the super villains I
might add so this is how we are going to
see all of those characters who have
been rumored to be appearing in Deadpool
3. we're talking about some old
Fantastic Four members like Jessica Alba
possibly of course we would love to see
Chris Evans return and play the Human
Torch because Deadpool would have a
great joke about that but of course
we've heard that characters like Elektra
are going to be returning it's possible
Nicholas Cage's Ghost Rider could be
there and of course the big ones are the
X-Men we know that several X-Men from
the original X-Men movies are going to
be in Deadpool 3 and it looks like this
is how that is going to go down the TVA
is actually grabbing these characters
from different universes and putting
them all into one Universe which is safe
kind of like a Noah's Ark now this is
going to go directly into Avengers
Secret Wars so this is one of the ways
that secret Wars is going to feature so
many cameos like I said of course we've
been hesitant to start to expect a lot
of cameos to show up but it really does
sound like this movie is going to have a
ton of cameos and yesterday Insider my
time to shine hello who is a very
reliable Insider Source said this this
is what secret Wars is gonna be like and
she tweeted out a fan made poster by
Affinity X Ben solo underscore cup
credit to him but the poster shows a ton
of different heroes from Toby Maguire's
Spider-Man and to Ghost Rider to The
Punisher Hugh Jackman's Wolverine the
original Blade the original Hulk Lou
ferrigno's Hulk is in there bunch of
different members of the Fantastic Four
of course we have the X-Men in there and
Venom is even in there as well so my
time to shine hello is heavily implying
that this is indeed what we are going to
be getting for Avengers Secret Wars it
is going to be character and Cameo
filled and if we really think about it
it just makes sense and it would be a
complete and total waste for Marvel
Studios to not do this with Avengers
Secret Wars because they have already
set up the story to do it with the
Multiverse collapsing and incursions
happening in universes colliding it
wouldn't make sense to not show Heroes
from other universes in this film it
would just be bad writing because it's
all there it's all already laid out it's
set up perfectly so are we gonna see a
bunch of cameos and Avengers Secret Wars
yes and we're gonna see them come from
everywhere from the old Fox X-Men movies
the old Spider-Man movies with Toby
McGuire and Andrew Garfield in fact Sony
Pictures UK last week teased a Venom
crossover between Tom Hardy's Venom and
Topher Grace's Venom they posted it to
tick tock and then they deleted it so
we're wondering well why would you post
it and delete it what are you hiding is
this actually going to happen well it is
actually a possibility in Avengers
Secret Wars we have talked about this
recently but Sony and Marvel Studios
have been playing nice together we've
already had a crossover in the MCU with
the Sony universe in our universe Tom
Hardy's venom has been in the MCU we
have seen this in two post credit scenes
granted he went back but I would be
shocked if he didn't show up for Secret
Wars and possibly toe for Grace's Venom
as well then we have the other
characters like Elektra The Punisher Etc
but then we also have different variants
of the same characters that we know for
example and I'll just use one that a lot
of people are familiar with because it
was talked about a lot Tom Cruise could
show up as a variant of Iron Man John
Krasinski could show up again as a
variant of Captain America because we
know that he auditioned for the role of
Captain America so that would be a
really cool kind of Easter egg thing
that Marvel Studios could do there that
is indeed an alternate universe an
alternate timeline where instead of
Chris Evans Becoming Captain America
John Krasinski landed the role the same
thing goes for his wife Emily Blunt she
could have been Black Widow but it ended
up being Scarlett Johansson however we
could see a black widow variant played
by Emily Blunt also we could see the
original Black Widow for the MCU
Scarlett Johansson's Black Widow return
and play a variant of herself the same
thing goes for Robert Downey Jr and
Chris Evans they could return still as
Iron Man still as Captain America but
from a different Universe really the
potential for this movie is and has
always been absolutely insane if Marvel
Studios does it right so it's really
great to hear that they are planning on
just including a ton of different
characters and cameos in this movie and
it sounds like it is going to indeed
start with Deadpool 3 where we start to
see all these different cameos now it's
all Really Gonna start to go down in
Loki season two so be sure to tune in to
the first episode next week because what
makes Loki so important is they are
going to further explore the actual
mechanics of the Multiverse and Kang the
Conqueror and his variants so it sounds
like things are about to get really
really good and everything is going to
start to really lead up to Secret Wars
now and that makes us all super excited
but let us know your thoughts about all
of this in the comments down below what
do you think about it and who do you
hope to see what Cameo would you really
really love to see show up in Avengers
Secret Wars or Deadpool 3 let us know in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items as well you can find us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf